[Music]
mike tyson raves in full bloom captured
the art of fighting
the hollywood reporter says it's mallet
meet scorsese
[Applause]
in full bloom available now on amazon
prime video
about a year ago i i did
i did shrooms okay and it was
yesterday
so so check this one out um and it was
with a shaman
you know she was hot they normally are
you know i haven't no i've been feeling
overweight shaman chick yet
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hotbox with mike tyson i'm
your co-host aka
triple c henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
and we have a very special guest tonight
legendary fighter all-time great hall of
famer
oscar de la hoya come on mike yeah let's
go let's hear it
what's up man sixth division
wait i got i just got introduced by mike
no i just said what you were i feel the
truth yeah that's true
that's true thank you mike yeah thank
you for having me some other [ __ ] i left
out but this is well you guys
love
to tie the truth how can miserable
yeah why is that well because i mean
aside aside from aside from like my kids
you know aside from you know you
i'm you know with family and you know
when i'm not boxing i'm [ __ ]
miserable
[ __ ] miserable for some strange
reason it's like
it's like boxing like boxing
is like my savior it's like you know
boxing it's
that's all i know that's all i know it's
i started fighting when i was five years
old you know
and so when i'm not thinking about
boxing when i'm not thinking about
fighting somebody or or training or you
know it's like
[ __ ] what do i go do i'm going to go
[ __ ] destroy my life
i want to go you know but you're a small
guy you can go into enterprise business
never destroy your life yeah but yeah
but i think more with him mike is what
i'm getting from oscar i think it's more
of like
the high the you know i mean like his
purpose is almost like he
you've done boxing for so long that it's
it's the biggest high that you could get
oh bro but
i mean but you're right mike it's like
okay i mean i have all this business
i have you know it's you know i'm a
smart guy you know i know how to
for some reason we have something and
that's built in our head you know in our
heart that that
that you know it's always gonna be okay
you know
and you know business is good family's
good
you know but it's like we're always torn
in between
we're always like getting pulled here
and then getting pulled here you know
and it's like
we have it's like a balancing act you
know yeah how would you want your life
to be a perfect life for you would be
what
wow that that's that's that's you know
it's crazy i've never been asked that
yeah
it's a deep question but uh a perfect
life you know obviously there's no
perfection but
you know a perfect life for me would be
not to be selfish you know
so it's almost like so oscar it's almost
like peace
contentment yeah it's like so do your
selfishness um
and fill you with guilt yeah it's it's
it's part of that it's part of the guilt
what is your selfishness what is your
requirement for me
well i mean obviously not always putting
myself
first you know in whatever situation and
what it
it's like not not that we're not that
i'm a bad guy or a mean guy or no
it's just like sometimes you just have
to put people first you know well that's
that's self-preservation how did that
become bad that's the number one law
self-preservation you can't help
yourself you can't help anybody else
right i wouldn't take that as being
selfish you know that's a different you
need another that's interesting
that's when i started thinking to myself
like man i must have
i must have a [ __ ] angel looking
looking after me
we all have something yeah yeah
somewhere i don't know i don't
understand it either
no and and you do oscar because
obviously i've man i grew up
you know being mexican-american mike
oscar's the highest
the highest of the highest you know what
i'm saying for a mexican american
because
it's not it's not a i'm not pure mexican
i'm mexican american yeah there's
what are they called like we're not from
there we're not from here we're like
we're just [ __ ] lost well
we just have to find something to
dislike the fight
you know that's just no but you talk
about you talk about your your guardian
angel man i feel like
knowing your story i know your whole
story oscar like i read your
story while i was at the olympics man i
ended up winning gold you know what i'm
saying like
your story is part of my story bro as
crazy as that sounds
but i remember reading reading about you
and you know your mom
you know passing away of cancer in 1990
man and then you're going off
1992 winning the olympic yeah winning
the olympic gold man
you know talk about a little bit about
that and yeah you know what's crazy is
is when when he talks about like my mom
passing away and all
it's like it's still it's still it still
hurts you know it's still it's still
here
you know and it's been it's been a while
it's been it's been a long time and i've
done a lot of work
to to get over her to not not to get
over her but to
to get over the pain but it's still
there you know and it still eats me and
it still it still just grabs on to me
you know
you know they call that now many
um successful people that started at
nothing suffer
it's called survivor's guilt huh
elaborate on that mike what do you mean
by that i'm usually we're in the streets
and there's guys smarter than us
stronger than us
more connected than us matter of fact
we're afraid of them
and we surpassed them and in our minds
we
look so up to them so much and now
they've look we can't even see them
they're bugs now
you know yeah i i understand i
understand
and then you feel guilty yeah how do you
do that and then matter of fact you feel
guilty because
in a way they start to um they start to
dislike you in a way
and you're still nice to them by paying
their bills and doing nice different
but they still even have after all that
they still dislike you because they
can't they're not in position to do that
for somebody
you you know you know you you touch on
an
interesting point mike because i i feel
that same way i feel [ __ ] guilty
guilty because you know what i'm okay
i'm happy that i have all this like
success right
i was able to you know be one of the
few or whatever to to to to make money
and keep it right
and make but but but then it's like i
think to myself
why the [ __ ] do i deserve that oh god
please please please
you know what i'm saying yeah but you do
but
but it's that guilt it's that guilt and
and it just keeps eating you inside and
like i say to myself [ __ ] i'm not smart
enough to [ __ ] you know see that's
listen
but you just said well i'll let you talk
about that only a good person would say
that myself selfish [ __ ] would
never think that yeah that would never
come in his mind that he's selfish what
do you [ __ ] mean
i'm selfish i can't think about i take
care of me don't i
you know you you know one one one person
i'm not sure who it was a long time ago
told me uh
you know what it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
what you think or how smart you are
whatever just make sure you hire smarter
people than you
yeah because if you're the smartest guy
that's in the wrong room
exactly i know that man it's crazy it's
great and it's it's pretty crazy we're
talking about this because
this is like [ __ ] that i've never like i
can even talk about
you know and and and
and to me it's like it's all like
bottled in like
i have so much [ __ ] bottled in you know
starting with my mother passing away but
it goes way beyond
ever since i was like seven years old
yeah because even though
obviously even knowing your story too
even with your father man because your
father was always hard on you man and
obviously your siblings were always
there to
to help you you know what i'm saying so
i wonder if it's like the the passing of
your mother
like the the strong activity of your
father man like you know what i'm saying
there's a lot man there's a lot in this
like
oscar i have a lot of passion for you
know that you're a special person
you do know that right come on come on
please have an ego you do not
i i i feel there's something special
there
and when it gets unlocked yeah i want
you to know that don't think you're a
[ __ ] up person you're a very special
person and we need you that's real talk
thank you bro don't beat yourself up
thank you thank you
i i i do beat myself up a lot i know you
don't deserve it
yeah that's cool man i appreciate that
it's crazy because
it started at such a young age you know
your boxing career right
i mean was it you do you think part of
your childhood was like stolen
and taken away from you a little bit at
such a young age man
100 yeah you get it you know i mean i
i got i have other [ __ ] that happened to
me when i was a kid
that got stolen from you know it's like
you know and it [ __ ] hurts and it
and and and and that's why i tell mike
like [ __ ] i'm
what do i have i have boxing thank god
for boxing because
if i didn't have boxing i would be who
knows where
you know because boxing to me was i got
in the ring and i
i want to beat some [ __ ] ass up you
know to let that anger out to
to to you know the the hurt the pain you
know
did you use it that way too mike when
that obviously when the person is
absolutely
pigeon man was that i thought about
people that bullied me did bad things to
me when
i couldn't defend myself yeah i put all
that in the pot
so you found your outlet mic through the
frustration through the haze 100
yeah the unboxing the box you saved your
life mike
hey look 100 things yeah yeah
yeah it's it's that and that's why i i
feel
i feel connected you know i've always
felt connected with mike and i've always
admired him and i've always appreciated
him i've always
to me here it's like fox talking to
mike is like literally i feel like i'm
talking to the mirror you know
yeah yeah i'm sorry and talk about
elaborate a little bit on that house
because i remember i was on the back
talking to you
and you said there's a lot of parallels
with me and mike yeah yeah so there's a
story
check it out that i i was gonna saved
but i wanted i wanted to wait for for
mike
um so
about a year ago i i did
i did shrooms okay and it was
[Laughter]
so so check this one out so
um and it was with a shaman you know
and she was hot they normally are you
know
i haven't known i haven't thought that
it was charming chicken yeah
it was the real deal right it was the
real deal
it was at home i felt safe you know
and so she gives me these it's like a
micro dosing right they call it right so
i
take them and she starts talking to me
about my my past like she starts telling
me like you know what
what affects you as a kid or this and
that and that when we're talking you
know
so then we go into my a room you know
where she has candles and everything and
so we
we sit down and
i close my eyes mike i
i turned into like i turned into like
like
like a substance i i got out of my body
i turned into a substance and i started
floating like in the galaxy it does it
to you
you know i was in and then all of a
sudden
i dive into the ocean okay i dive into
the ocean
and i'm just like i'm water i'm i'm i
don't know what i am
i dive and it's beautiful it's like
[ __ ] finding nemo it's beautiful
colorful everything and i keep going
down keep going down
and all of a sudden i stop and i'm
looking but it's like i'm water i'm part
of the water you know and then behind
like the seaweed
there's a there's a thing a presence
okay
and all i feel is that that's my mother
you know i feel that's my mother and
then
the the thing starts bowing down to me
and right there and then i felt that she
forgave me
you know and how how long ago was this
oscar that was a year ago
and then i shoot right back up and then
and and now i'm feeling like man she
forgave me she forgave me
and then the shaman like she speaks a
few words and says now let's go to
little oscar
and all of a sudden i see i see myself
as the seven-year-old
right in front of me you know and then
she tells me feel them closer
and he's getting closer and you feel
them closer he's getting closer and all
of a sudden i have i opened my eyes
because i got scared
i got scared i i i haven't been able to
face
that little oscar it's an oscar see
you're talking to me
and henry right now but right now
there's [ __ ] out here to think
you're crazy as a [ __ ]
you know i hear you we've been on that
ride so we know
you know this is the real deal but now
there's people looking after these from
craters
it's deep it's deep no oscar you talk
about fruit do you feel like you need
forgiveness for your mom
you think your mom would be dis you know
what i'm saying like elaborate
touch up on that oscar i think there's a
lot of um
i think there's a lot in us a lot in me
that that i have to release and work on
and let go
and because there's a lot of pain you
know there's a lot of [ __ ]
pain you know a lot of times we put it
on themselves you know
i'm mad that i couldn't buy my mother
nice stuff
yeah that's one thing she never had nice
stuff
you know what you know it's crazy my mom
passed away
before i can buy her nice stuff you know
yeah i know that feeling
yeah yeah it's crazy man it's it's it's
it's it's pain it's pain it's [ __ ]
painful man
you know what what's crazy mike is um
i'm i'm coming back you should i want to
fight why not
it's it's it's it's the way you were
saying like you know
something told me you have to fight or
fight
i feel the same way listen um boxing
[ __ ] i didn't feel that way i never
wanted to do this [ __ ] again
listen i don't know what it is i wish i
could but i'm just taking advantage of
what it's giving me first man
it's almost like we have to go it's
almost like the medicine's out on earth
it's up to us to find it and
yeah just and this gave me a new life i
was always miserable i was always hating
and jealous and all that [ __ ] and just
gave me a whole different perspective in
life
i'll tell you the truth mike um i i've
you know i i have this
you know it there's a balance you know
there's a balance that
i'm always trying to look for that i'm
always trying to like find you know and
and a lot of times i [ __ ] go this
down spiraling down you know and
for some reason i catch myself bring
myself back
and and that's my mom you know that's my
mom like [ __ ] pulling my hair my
grenades you know
in spanish we call it yes i can pull my
hair and [ __ ]
hey get get it get in line again you
know what i'm saying that's
that's why i said i have i have a spirit
i have a an angel that's looking
down at but can you believe that
my mother never told me she loves me
really yeah
and i never had the opportunity to tell
her i love her you know how painful that
is yeah but you know
pain you don't know what she's been to
to not be able to say that to you no no
but i
i actually understand it now yeah i
understand why
she couldn't say it because maybe her
mother treated her wrong
you know it's not her fault you know but
but the pain that i feel that that i was
left with yeah you know what i'm saying
but she gave you her blood a
characteristic she gave you your you
know
she gave you your uh all your um your
quality the right becoming the champion
yeah
that's what that's why did you ever
think of that yeah no i now
now i have after the shrooms that i did
after the shrooms i figured out that
you know what she gave me everything i
have
so i i cannot hate her enough you know i
cannot hate her he hates a big word i
cannot have
never ever the same thing man like not
that i have mommy issues
but it's almost like exact same thing my
mom never told me she loved me she's
alive now
yeah but i go back and look at her life
man she was raised by
family she was selling ice creams in
mexico city and she was sold
you know from family to family to do
that so she never really had structure
and you know i mean when i'm saying this
she never really had nobody really told
her
this is why something's like for me like
it's hard for me to tell my mom i love
you
right yeah you know what i'm saying like
it's it's different
it's different but it's the same you
know it's like my father my father
started
he started me at five years old my
father was a fighter and my grandfather
was a fighter
so at five years old he you know put on
the gloves i had no choice you know i'm
gonna be a fighter
so he trained me this and that he never
got involved
you know like managing me or anything he
that was cool because he
kind of stood back you know and
just about two years ago okay
two years ago i never heard him tell me
son i'm proud of you or i love you
never okay never
so then one day after i did this the the
the shrooms
okay one day i told i i get you know
what i'm gonna tell them
i'm gonna [ __ ] go up to tell him that
she did the shrooms or no no no
that i love him that i love him
because he's not gonna tell me because
maybe he doesn't know how i know he
loves me
but he doesn't know how so i [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] scared as hell going up to
my dad and telling
and and and i said dad oh i love you i
love you
you know pat him on the back you know
and you know what he did
what [ __ ] started crying i love you
too
i love you too and ever since then i
can't stop
i can't stop telling him i love him you
know you know what i'm saying
yeah somebody has to unlock the 100
yeah that's exactly what it is mike are
you like that with your kids mike do you
tell your kids
all day when you're a kid mike did
people tell you they loved you
when you were a kid that wasn't
important to me it wasn't important to
you no
yeah we were we weren't the world i mean
the street guys loved me those people my
family loved didn't matter
yeah it was it was it was
for me it was for me it was always being
in the streets with my friends with
my whole life consisted of that yeah
that's just in the streets and then when
i found boxing
my love was my my my
my distraction you know my it was it was
in the ring you know
got a gold medal to the golden boy what
kind of pressure was that oh
which i might well check this out so my
my mother had just passed away
yeah and so i was 17 years old yeah as
part of the olympics
90 right now i would know she yeah late
night it's about a year
she passed away and so the pr i had
retired i said i'm going to retire from
boxing my mom's gone that's it i'm no
no more boxing for me and something i
used to live in a garage
and with my brother and something like
at 4 am in the morning
woke me up and i felt her presence
and that she told me you know go go
go win go go you know go pursue your
goal your dreams whatever
and that's when i came back to boxing
because i had retired for like five
months
you know when you were an amateur yeah
yeah jesus
yeah i said i should i said [ __ ] boxing
i'm done
and so that voice that feeling and then
i had to re-qualify
how did it feel to get back in that zone
fighting again
it's like tying your shoes man like
riding a bike like you know
at that point everything is just it's
it's mental it's it's
it's like [ __ ] like all right this is
this is my destiny you know
it's pretty crazy man yeah and it's
crazy because the guy that the only
when you go the guy is a marco rudolph
right from germany
yeah chairman he had beat you a year
prior
world championships so so i fight i
fight this
i go to the world championships in
australia in 91
and the first fight okay we have to
win six fights to win the gold right the
tournaments you know [ __ ] you have to
fight everybody which is hard
the first guy i fight
germany and he beats me and that's the
first time i lost like in nine years
[ __ ] nine years and i was devastated
my world
crumbled i i locked myself in the room
for like eight days while the
tournament's still going on
you know all my coaches they were
worried banging on the door and you know
and
i would let a couple of my you know
fellow athletes in you know but i was
depressed
at that age depressed because i lost
and i thought everybody just hated me
because i lost
you know because [ __ ] i have i have
nobody
now you know it's like i i have nobody
i'm lost i'm alone i'm
you know because every time i was
winning
i had everybody around me everybody
loving me
everybody's saying [ __ ] you're the
you're the you're the you're the
you're the you're gonna be the next
champion but when i lost
i told myself you're a [ __ ] miserable
[ __ ]
you know that's why you're so great
because
you tell yourself what people would
never tell you yeah
you know people say you're too hard on
yourself but you're hard enough for this
you know who you are right that's how i
am too
no nobody would never say what's really
wrong with us
so we have to say right mike was there
one loss for you mike that really uh
he locked himself in the room for eight
days an amateur fight
really never happens that much in the
pros the amateur fights really are your
demons
really yeah which fight do you recall
michael what did you do
a fight with this guy named craig payne
from
um laverne livonia michigan
heavyset overweight guy but he could
fight number one guy
i beat him three rounds no doubt and
they gave him the decision i got mad i
threw the trophy and i was just
crying and crying he was crying yeah
cried from indianapolis i guess it was
crash from there to new york just kept
crying
you know you know what's crazy is god
no i mean and i understand because
i i locked myself in a room for eight
days because i
i let everybody down i left yeah i let
myself down
but i let everybody down you know
because all you hear people hate the
next chant right here
next chapter in the world and you're
losing fights getting knocked out and
[ __ ]
this is the next one but mike but mike
check this out now check this out now
tell them the rest of the story tell
them what happened in 92. so i
requalified for the olympics i i
my mom's passed and then i go to
barcelona
and so i'm in the zone something's
telling me [ __ ] be in the zone i
i swear right now it feels like it was
all a blur
i don't know how to really explain how i
feel you know it's like a blur bro
so i go to barcelona i win one fight i
beat the cubans i beat this i beat the
african the and then i'm thinking to
myself [ __ ] where's the german guy
and back then they didn't tell you who
you're gonna fight
so all of a sudden i'm in the gold medal
round and who's in the ring the [ __ ]
german
the [ __ ] the only guy i lost in nine
years
the same guy that beat you in the first
round at the world championship 91.
and and it was like i felt like i was
floating in the ring man
knocked them down what beat them easy
won the gold
i was on the podium and they start
playing the national anthem
and i all i can see is my mom's face and
then i free i just freeze i can't cry i
can't
i can't laugh i can't be happy
you know i have no emotion i'm just
frozen
and i get out of the ring and you know
the interview and in the bottom of the
ring
nbc i think was was doing the the
telecast
and the and the and the guy the
interview he tells me
so how do you think your mom feels and i
just [ __ ]
cried like a baby for [ __ ] i don't
know like a year
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying yeah it
was crazy it was crazy
it was it was all all those feelings man
all those
emotions and you know what's crazy is is
my mom used to beat me up every day
she used to beat me up every day every
[ __ ] day
you know with the belt and then yeah
every [ __ ] day man
you know how crazy is that every [ __ ]
day
you know and yeah it's it's
i think i think everything that we lived
that it just it built me
to be of to be this [ __ ]
fighter you know yeah of course no
wonder we're fighters
yeah when i talk to mike we talk i talk
about this all the time but we get boxes
here all the time
in my opinion i know mike feels the same
way amateur boxing and boxing is the
most purest form of boxing it's the
hardest
thing even more so than professionals
man because
you got every four years to win olympic
gold medal every you have to make the
olympic team you have to make the world
the world team
and that this is how you go and you get
a chance to represent this is
interesting
for three minutes or three rounds these
guys are like
moving for six rounds before they attack
you they're attacking you right there as
soon as the bell attack
thing clinch they only they gotta make
those rounds get those points in big
time yeah
make time out of it those two those
amateur fights those tough amateurs like
to be the hardest fights you have in
your whole professional life
yeah yeah i did a little bit of average
i was like dude i've done mma
russ ufc wrestling amateur box is one of
the hardest shits i've ever done i
thought i thought i was gonna die
a heart attack right yeah and and by the
way i mean
what you guys do like mma not right
mike then my steps on my toe i'm tapping
out
kudos to you guys man because it's it's
you guys
not only have to like know how to strike
you have to know how to wrestle you have
to know how to
so it's like different different what do
you call them like different uh
categories techniques you know yeah just
styles
yeah styles there's tons of them right
yeah yeah so it's
it's much respect man much respect crazy
i asked mike this all the time man you
won your first world title but when is
it because he
he always says man the time that i did
feel like a world champion i really feel
like the best is when i beat larry
holmes
yeah for you oscar yeah who's that one
fight
that finally made you feel okay i am the
man
i'm still trying to [ __ ] figure that
one out i think the fight where i
felt i think perfect was when i fought
chavez
the first time first time yeah i think i
think
i was if there's one time i was 100
it had to be that fight you did great in
that fight i was pissed off that you won
that fight but
i think your best fight was with
trinidad oh
never too many punches like that yeah
that was i was on my toes and
i kind of [ __ ] up in the last three
rounds
last three rounds you know they said
that i boxed too much and what the [ __ ]
you boxing i bought it too much
you started boxing that was the game
plan exactly
but right that was the game plan right
now yeah you you do some [ __ ]
comments and
and and and that's the crazy part is the
pressure of of of
the pressure of um of all the people you
know
that was a hell of a night man but you
know what's crazy is like
okay i feel i won the fight you know you
know when you
they they they sound the last bell and
you feel you won
or you lost right you know inside the
ring you feel you if you won or lost
like i felt i wanted this i was going to
trigger that right but i thought you won
yeah that was a robbery man i i imagine
man especially
god and then and then eventually you
marrying
and being you know having kids with the
puerto rican how was it
being in puerto rico i actually i
actually lived in puerto rico for
six years you know it was crazy
everywhere i would go
i mean trinidad is the king in puerto
rico right
but it's crazy because cnn and mike why
i look up in the sky like that
i'm looking at my mother yeah yeah ever
before every fight
that jab was working that night that jab
man that jab was working at night
yeah cause you're at 40 at most you're
at 40 and this was like one of the first
time you started going up to 47 right
yeah this was this was 47 because
trinidad was a big boy yeah
you know and he had that left hook yeah
yeah
you know what made me you know what made
me kind of like get him out of balance
all the time is because
every time he would plant the left foot
i knew i knew
how to move and when to move you know
you know who trained me there
uh gil clancy yeah
gail clancy yeah bill clancy trained me
there and he says oscar
if you stay on your toes turn that will
not find you
yeah i actually had a i actually had a
broken ankle uh
in this fight yeah i had i had twisted
see the combination she was throwing
back then
you've never done that left left to
right ankle oscar
uh look at that look at this [ __ ] it's
like old school i actually had duct tape
on my ankle
yeah that's the mexican thing yeah oh
dude i couldn't cancel this fight no i
mean everything was sold out every you
know it's like
it was the fight or the millennium the
millennium or whatever you know
what does george lopez say the the put
up put some tape in uh
a brick yeah see i knew i knew i knew
that every time i would throw a punch he
would throw his left hook
always keep that hand up you know yeah
which is crazy because both you guys
specialty was a left hook
i mean i felt pretty good there i mean i
just came forward
no one no one listen nobody boom yeah
boom
this is like 20 21 years ago this was
back in 2001 right
this is the best episode you looked like
i was 99 right
right yeah rolling and yeah i mean
people asked me like
look this is the best episode
beautiful yeah can we see a little bit
of oscar and judo cesar chavez one
oh [ __ ] okay because that's what hey
thomas
man i you know i i love chavez man
i freaking love him he's yeah he's
fighting uh he's fighting
he is and i've been seeing that they've
been uh he's fighting uh
camacho camacho jr
there he is and this was at 40 or 47. i
forget this was uh this was 140.
oh this was 40 yeah
i felt so like i felt nobody can touch
me here at 140.
you know because the jab man the jab i
was sticking out the jab
no especially your height too by your
you know and you know what's funny when
when i was fighting chavez um because
he's my hero
you know everybody's here um
and when i was in the ring and they were
introducing us
i was literally telling myself i was
like i was like a little kid like oh
[ __ ] i'm fighting my hero chavez yeah
you know and i had to snap out of it
that must be a trip yeah
yeah it's crazy too because it's keep
hitting them huh i think oscar other
than you
winning the olympic gold medal would you
say this is this is
your greatest win in boxing um beating
the legend uh
chavez i don't know man because you know
it's
this fight here was a double-edged sword
for me man because
[ __ ] one can't cantaloupe yeah when i
beat chavez like all the
all the mexican community just fell on
top of me and they yeah
nobody i'm surprised nobody attacked you
physically oh
they did yeah oh hell yeah oh let's
imagine that thing that's what happened
yeah i couldn't i couldn't go anywhere
i saw them i saw them man i saw them do
some work on something yeah
it's his birthday today 70 years old
brutal durant on the phone
ah
june 16 1983
madison square garden you beat iran
broccoli for the
[Laughter]
happy birthday happy birthday brother i
love you
well he's in panama right he's got to be
a panel he looks like
every time every time he's every time he
sees i'm sure you guys have you guys go
way back
every time he sees me he goes uh hey hey
uh yeah you're getting a little fat
you're getting a little fat he [ __ ]
with people
he does he does so everybody so once you
once you beat uh
chavez man do you feel like you were
like the stepchild like the redheaded
child you know what i'm saying
this is the difference mike i couldn't
go anywhere man yeah we're messing we're
mexican descent but we're not
from mexico and it's different that's
the thing it's like
you're that's why i told you it's like
you're not from here you're not from
there that's ridiculous anything they
should think
that represents mexico that's positive
it's mexican
yeah but where would you take out the
idol when you take out the
team that's just something you had to be
born to handle
yeah yeah you know what's crazy
i because i always respect the chavez
and i love chavez and
i always the people that were against me
you know
the older people that were against me
because they're the kids were with me
you know because they were born in the
u.s yes the parents were born in mexico
so
i always i always kept that message like
you know hey let's be proud
let's be proud of mexico let's be part
of the us you know
that's what that's what the evil
government wants they want you to hate
each other yeah
yeah you know they want us to hate each
other right exactly
but you had an opportunity to fight
pernell whitaker
and and i was going to ask you that i
was going to say who's the best
pernell uh [ __ ] floyd who's the best
be on purpose be honest in your heart
yeah trickier
man was a slippery [ __ ]
he is so weird right it's so weird yeah
oh man he gives you his back he like he
like look at you give you his bag
hey at one time at one time i was and
that was a big walter weight right
and and so per now at one point i was
like
and he was looking at me like [ __ ]
and i missed every punch
he was a son of a [ __ ] he was good he
was yeah he was
right what about uh what about macho
camacho oh about this crazy
crazy he wasn't that slick but dude he
and you hit him a lot bro he only
wore those 12 rounds dude i was
surprised i dropped him i was surprised
i think the 11th round i hit him with a
right hand he was going back and he
boom i was surprised because he had a
good chin
you know and people people i don't think
people respect them that much uh super
tucker
he's got power good techniques yeah and
he's footballers
well he has some balls he is so crazy
that's why everybody loves me it's so
crazy
did you get a chance to see his
documentary on h on show time i did
right yeah yeah
he said they said he had that one fight
and he said he used to fight all the
time and he just said like
that one fight just scared the [ __ ] out
of him dude and he became more defensive
yeah can i tell you a story uh so so we
we we make a bet
he wasn't in here
so the bell rings the bell rings right
and i tell my my cut man hey give me the
scissors
so i run to camacho's a corner and he
goes
no no please no no no this is that's
what happened
hey you're not right you didn't tell him
to lie you you broke the promise right
there this is
i'm lost here after you beat him right
the the deal was she cut his hands
no way can you see that can you see if
that's great i want the curl yeah the
braid
and the and i i actually felt bad
i felt bad i said you know what because
yeah but you're not going man
that's what a fighter man i mean look at
his career
when he fought the tasmanian devil many
people
he beat these guys there oh man who else
did he beat up he
man man he beat sugar ray leonard bro
sugary leonard
you beat a guy like that that's one of
the things oh you know what let's just
check this out
that's my dad you guys turn it up dude
slip thing in his hand
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was like hey
i want that yeah
it's really lonely you're shy bro you're
a shark dude
at one point i say hey give me the
scissors man i want to go
oh [ __ ] he was dude hey and and
softballs are [ __ ]
tricky man he's fast yeah cause he's
fast you know what was crazy
my job was working really good great job
you have a great job thank you legendary
great guy oh
you know it's crazy mike back then when
when we used to fight
if you're like if you're 30 you're like
over the hill right
[Laughter]
it's really longer than that yeah yeah
it is
that's your brother right right this was
vegas
oh man remember the michael buffer
nothing like
he's good bro oh man 25 another yeah so
he didn't want he didn't want it
i thought she cut it i was like that no
no he didn't want it he didn't want it
he didn't want it at all you know one
thing i'm i i
i really admire uh mike
that i understand as well is i i saw an
interview
not too long ago of you where you said
the belts
these belts don't mean [ __ ] no
hey i love that i love that
and i understand why like nobody else
will understand
i understand why those [ __ ] belts
brought me [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying number trouble
right
elaborate on that mic sometimes having
that
kind of success man listen just think
about it um yeah
let's go back to him coming to iran
coming into the ring
i want you just to remember this yeah
man this was this was a holiday man for
every time oscar you would fight man for
the mexican community cinco de mayo
in september no but not even sequel
every time you would fight
you see all those people see him walking
to all those people yeah you see that
he's damaged
yeah this is what you do for a living
you know you think you're a normal
person
yeah being worshipped pretty much yeah
that's what you're fully now you think
he's not i think he's normal
this [ __ ] drives you crazy man you can't
do wrong you know when you start
thinking
you're [ __ ] powerful you know you
think you're god
that's what people don't understand it's
not our fault
yeah that's true society's fault they
put us on that pedal they put us on a
pedestal
you see why you see a lot you see why i
was excited
to because because i i i i know
i i i i identify with yeah but but coach
you don't think coach you would kind of
feel some of that some of that void that
you sometimes feel
you think you don't have it's the
patience huh you think
bro you've been there you've been the
best you understand what it takes
is that why we're we're like we're like
we're like machines man you know like no
but no he doesn't
yes i'm saying do you see that right
there
he's still there right now now he wants
to be a normal person though
now he can't because he's still that
yeah that's why i say he's damaged once
you
let you experience that stuff for you
damage
hey you see floyd he's damaged he wants
to come back and fight you see that's
what that does that's
that's jesus i came back we're not right
that [ __ ] you up
yeah it does you're damn hey and we'll
do it until we're [ __ ]
dead six feet under damage yeah
you know yeah i'm sure some of your ufc
got two that damaged you man
how could you be a normal person every
time somebody see you it's like this
it's it's like a [ __ ] time you go
outside with your kids they have
family dreams like that it's like a
[ __ ] drug you want it you need it you
[ __ ] you know it's like
damn like your masculinity yeah yeah
and it's not our fault somebody told us
this is the best thing in life yeah
and money and this is like not working
for us
right yeah this is like not working for
us yeah this is not working this is hey
give me some of that toad god damn it
you can try to let some toad yeah jesus
yeah this is that's that's you know
oscar i think of your career men and
you know you've done mike tyson's done a
lot for boxing you've
you've done a lot for boxing and one
name that i'm gonna bring up
is because i feel like it's you're the
reason why he is where he's at like i
really do
floyd mayweather it wasn't until he
fought you
yeah where he truly became a megastar
right you know obviously the talking all
that other stuff
i appreciate you know what what
what we did together and you know we had
a big fight and
you know but it's like
i mean everybody everybody has their
time you know but tyson had his time i
had my time you know
floyd had his time everybody's having
their time you know and it's like
it's but listen it's different with me
and you
some people when they do their time is
over we still have the residue of our
time lingered
you know what i mean right people say
you hear all these people know you you
you're still
big time idle but just imagine this man
being a mexican
and you were in mexico you hear
americans golden boys and mexicans how
much pride does she give you
oh and another state makes people want
to kill you
exactly you know isn't that crazy that's
crazy but how could that one make you
hate somebody if you have that
descent you should be proud should be
proud man
it's crazy it's it is crazy i don't even
know i'm staying and
it's just crazy but it's true it's true
and i and i
and i understand it man and it's it's
like and it feels good to talk about it
because
everything's all bottled in you know and
it's it's you know it's
it it lets out the it lets out the you
know the
the yeah the bubbles you know yeah
of course man what they were saying the
transition from
from being a boxer oscar to being a
promoter man yeah
like how has that transition been man i
i have i have a special
quote i owe everything to boxing
you know why and what that everything is
is my life
boxing saved me boxing saved me i
and i and i and i wish it can continue
to save me
you know because if i didn't have boxing
and as much as i [ __ ] hate it
i love it because it saved my life you
know
and so being in haiti right yeah and
being you know being
being still involved and it's like
you're part of it and
it gives you those you know it's like
it's like me and tyson are gonna
you know be us forever
you know it's like we're a handful you
know like but this is what made us you
know this is what made us man and it's
it's like you [ __ ] love it and you
hate it you know
you know yeah because obviously and i
got to bring this up man because
obviously right now you know
you and canelo are beefy and uh
you're even you're even you know you're
even beefing with dana white and
rightfully so
no no no no i mean look this is what's
happening okay
and and and this might be my my fighter
juices flowing again you know and
it's like first of all you inspired me
mike because you know being what are you
56 mike
56 55 you know and looking as good
as you did against roy who's a boxer
who's a
master right and the and just for coming
back and doing
you inspired me so i said i want to do
it too
you know but in back of my head my
demons are telling me
no you got to do it [ __ ] i know
how that works
you know what i'm saying i know i know
your subconscious mind right
right and so so the fact
i want to do two of these fights you
know
i want to do it oh no hold on i want to
do two of these fights
and then guess what i want to do a real
fight
a 12-round fight with either floyd or
canelo
i've never heard no [ __ ] like this oh
what's your take back we should take on
that i want you to look in the cameras
and say that
yeah yeah i want to do in my third fight
coming back
i'm either going to call out floyd or
canelo
there we have it there we have it that's
what i'm talking about this is this
that's what separates oscar from the run
that's what separates you mike
your mentality i'm so excited to hear
that got me erect almost
before we wrap up here oscar what
members do you have of mike
oh man the the beautiful memories the
beautiful memories the the inspiring
ones
there's times that i've seen mike you
know
happy you know i you that that's why we
i i identify with mike i can see it i
can see it in his face
but it's it's a split second i don't
even even if it's two seconds or one sec
i can see it that's when i'm most happy
for mike
you know because it inspires me like
because if if he can do it i can do it
you know
you know what i'm saying like 100 you're
searching for something mike
you're you got it you whatever you know
what i can i can get it too
that that's why i never see any negative
in nobody
well man well oscar i just want to say
thank you dude like
you you may think you're selfish and we
all
partially are but i want to say bro that
you've made a huge impact man in my uh
my life man appreciate it brother and uh
i i had the opportunity to win a gold
medal too just like he was reading your
book leading up to
immigrant son yeah it's precious man
being from the same bloodline and from
the you know what i'm saying like being
mexican-american dude thank you i just
want to say thank you dude forever some
people want you to stay an immigrant you
know some of our people want us to stay
where we began at yeah yeah my closing
thoughts
closing thoughts for oscar man you want
to give give some advice for oscar
before you think
i think after after you some show more
love and consideration
some passion to yourself thank you you
know and that's not selfies
that's just your form of growth that we
all need to do
thank you and don't care what no one
says about you because everything you
have you have to realize that you earned
it
and i bet you this too just like myself
you work for everything you have but you
don't have everything you worked for
so just remember that i work they all
listen from your blood and sweat and
tears
thank you i will forever man thank you
mike appreciate it
i love thank you man a lot of love man
and we'll end it on that note everybody
you guys thanks for watching hop box
with mike tyson i'm your co-host aka
triple c henry cejudo
mike tyson in the house with the legend
oscar de la hoya
we out one
[Music]
so
you